les cabanes à huîtres est long et lourd
oui monsieur les cabanes à huîtres
peuvent rouvrir en france comme les
restaurants mais pour les menus comme
pour les accessoires les choses changent
avec qui on va arriver on va lui
présenter les cartes qui sont plastifiés
donc nettoyable et une fois que le
client a choisi on enlève les cartes et
on les pose dans un bac à d affecter un
mètre minimum entre les tables moins de
clients en perspective ce patron veut
quand même faire travailler tout le
monde pour qui aucune inégalité toutes
les équipes viennent à 20 heures au lieu
de 39 heures donc en gros tout le monde
va travailler mais un peu moins en grèce
le calcul est simple pour le nombre de
clients pas plus d'une personne par
mètre carré de la surface du restaurant
autre initiative pour faire un tri dans
ce restaurant turc on prend la
température de tous ceux qui veulent une
table du côté du portugal
il faut avoir un masque pour se déplacer
à l'intérieur du restaurant
mais oui on peut l'enlever pour manger
en belgique la réouverture c'est pour
lundi prochain les masques seront
obligatoires pour le personnel et
certains restaurateurs mise beaucoup sur
le plexiglas
je trouve que c'est une très bonne idée
pour la réouverture en espérant qu'on va
pas devoir garder sa des années mais je
crois pour la sécurité avant tout je
veux montrer à mes clients qui se
sentent à l'aise dans notre restaurant
en allemagne aussi on sort son au ruban
à mesurer deux mètres entre chaque table
et les clients sont aussi encouragés à
remplir une fiche pour qu'ils puissent
être retrouvés en cas de foyers de
contamination
et puis mauvaise nouvelle pour les
serveurs l'intelligence artificielle
leur fait de l'ombre aux pays bas 20
secondes pour débarrasser son plateau
avant qu'il ne débarrassent le plancher
un autre genre de convivialité ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal